الانجاب مساله مصريه واحيانا يصبح مساله
جدليه كما هي الحال في قصتنا اليوم الجدل
القديم جديد هل ينجب اكثر من يجني اكثر
ولو ان الارقام تظهر ان من يجني اكثره ومن
يتريث اكثر ربما وعيا منه المسؤوليات في
الكويت تجدد الجدل حول هذا الموضوع بعد ان
ابدت المحاميه الكويتيه مريم المؤمن رايها
بكل صراحه وقالت لي النبويه داخل المحدود
عليهم ان يتجنب انجاب الكثير من الاطفال
معطياتنا الحريه لذلك لاصحاب الدخل العالي
مريم المؤمن اشاره لانها لاقت هجوما كبيره
وتنمر عليها رغم ان هذا الرئيس اذا خرج عن
رجل لا يواجه بمثل هذا الهجوم في فقراتنا
اليوم نسال هل يجب مراعاه الحاله الماليه
قبل الانجاب ام انه كما يقول المثل الشعبي
كل طفل ياتي برسته في صباح العربيه لكن من
مصر نبدا حيث الكثافه السكانيه الاكبر في
المنطقه العربيه
مولود بكل 20 ثانيه فوصلت اعداد مصر الى
104 ملايين نسمه في اكتوبر مقارنه ب 130
فبراير الماضي بزياده تبلغ مليون نسمه في
سبعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
كادت السكانيه كانت وما زالت اكبر المشاكل
التي تواجهها الحكومات المصريه المتعاقبه
وتعتبر اكبر المعوقات لعجله التنميه لما
لها من اثار الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه كبيره
على المجتمع منها البطاله وزياده
الاستهلاك وانخفاض نصيب الفرد من الموارد
الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
اسباب عديده وراء هذه الزياده المستمره
وخاصه في الريف والاحياء الشعبيه منها
الزواج المبكر تفضيل الذكور عن الاناث في
بعض المجتمعات ووجود معتقدات الراسخه لدى
الاسر ان كثره الانجاب يعتبر عزوه وسند
[موسيقى]
ولمواجهه هذه الظاهره تضع الحكومه المصريه
مبادرات وبرامج قوميه لزياده الوعي باهميه
تنظيم الاسره ونشر عيادات وقوافل طبيه في
جميع القرى والمحافظات لتقديم الرعايه
الصحيه للامهات وتوفير وسائل تنظيم الاسره
مجانا بتكلفه وصلت الى 100 مليون جنيه
مصري سنوات
[موسيقى]
وقد اشار رئيس المصري في اكثر من لقاء عن
خطوره الزياده السكانيه في تعطيل حركه
التنميه سمر بشكل صباح العربيه من القاهره
رغم الانتشار الواسع لفكره الاسره الصغيره
في الدول المتقدمه لكن ايضا الاسره
الكبيره التي تعرف بانها العائله التي
لديها اربعه اطفال او اكثر لا تزالوا سمه
ظاهره في العديد من البلدان الغنيه حيث
ينشا ما يقرب الخمس الاطفال الذين
تتراوحوا اعمالهم بين الاحد عشر و13 عاما
في الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في اثر
مكونه من اربعه اطفال او اكثر
دراسه اجرتها جامعه واشنطن اشارت الى
تراجع معادلات الاطفال الذين تنجيبهم
المراه في 91 دوله حول العالم وفق الدراسه
فقط سجلت معدلات الخصوبه في النيجر الرقم
القياسي اذ بلغ متوسط انجاب المراه سبعه
اطفال مقابل طفل واحد تنجبه المراه
القبرصيه وتراجع معدل الانجاب في سنغافوره
واسبانيا والبرتغال والنرويج وكوريا
الجنوبيه الى اقل من طفلين وهي دول متقدمه
وترجع دراسه هذا الانخفاض الى تاخير فكره
الانجاب او التخليل تاماما عنها سين وراء
توفير المزيد من فرص التعليم والعمل للطفل
مع تحسن الظروف
في تنمر على المراه جيت انا بموضوع من
المواضيع مره تكلمت ايضا عن اللي يبيعون
بالرجي وهذا تكلمت عنهم بانه اذا انت كنت
يعني على قد حالك لا تجيب وايد يا خالي
يعني هديل برقبتك ما قلت لك ما قلت لك لا
تتزوج هذه سنه الحياه ولكن فكر بعقلك انك
تحد ما اعجبهم الكلام انا بعدها باسبوعين
رجل تكلم صفقه له
على كل لان في فقرت معه وضد معنا من عمان
ننشطه الاجتماعيه والكاتبه اسماء سليمان
الطويسي والاختصاص الاجتماعي الدكتور حسين
الخزاعي اهلا بكم يا دكتور واهلا بك هي
اسماء طب ابدا معك اسماء هل انت مع فكره
انه ربط عدد الابناء بمستوى دخل الفرد
انا معي 100% ما عرفت عدد الابناء حتى بغض
النظر على الوضع المادي سواء وضعك الماده
ممتاز او وضعت المادي يعني سيء المفروض
انه يكون في تنظيم
من مصلحه الاهل ومن مصلحه المجتمع ومن
مصلحه الابقار نفسهم
طيب دكتور يعني عديد من الدول تنادي
بتنظيم النسل يعني لكن الملفت في
المجتمعاتنا خصوصا العربيه حيث الكثافه
السكانيه العاليه الدخل دخل الفرد منخفض
هناك يعني نسبه انجاب عاليه كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك اجتماعيه
يمكن تفسير ذلك دينيا اولا وليس اجتماعيا
لانه هم يربطون دائما
الانجاب وكثره الانجاب هو نوع من المباهاه
وهو نوع من العزوه والكثره والرزق من الله
سبحانه وتعالى فهم يربطونها دائما بالدين
لهذا السبب اي اي انسان سواء كان عالم
مفكر
يتحدث في التحديد هذا سوف يواجه من قبل
المجتمعات العربيه بشكل عنيف جدا احنا مع
التنظيم احنا مع المباعد بين المواليد نحن
مع الحكمه نحن مع توفير كل العيش اللائق
السليم للمجتمع والدول ايضا كمان ولكن نحن
لسنا مع ان يقال كلمه تحديد الخطوره انه
دائما
المجتمعات تربط باي مناجاه تتعلق الناس ال
او بالانجاب بانها هذه مؤامره على الدول
العربيه وهذه مؤامره على الانجاب اذا احنا
بدنا ننجح في موضوع تنظيم الاسره علينا
اولا ان
نستخدم الوعي الديني الوعي الديني ان نفسر
للناس وهذا لا يتم على فكره من قبل
الدكتور
اجتماعيا واحد يكون عنده دخل منخفض او
محدود كيف يضمن مستوى معيشه اولاده في هذه
الحاله
في الحال هاي بدنا اولا بدنا مهم جدا
العادات والتقاليد والموروثات الاجتماعيه
نواجهنا نحن بربط تكاليف الحياه صعوبات
الحياه
بالمشقه وايه المعاناه التي
تحملها الاسره
الفقيره عدم القدره على توفير الغذاء
والدواء وفي بعض الامور المسكن والزواج
والحاجات الاساسيه لهم هي اهم قضيه القضيه
اذا بدنا ننجح مع المجتمعات العربيه بدنا
ننجح من خلال ماذا توظيف الدين والنصوص
الدينيه التي طالبت بالتكاتف والمحبه
والتراحم والتعادل وتوفير العيش الكريم
الى ابناء المجتمع وان كلهم دائما ان
نحطهم دائما على همم ماذا على المظهر
الحضاري في ماذا في عمليه المباعده بين
المواليد اولا اللي رحمت انفسه رحمه
الدوله ايضا الدول اللي الفقيره هاي كيف
بدها تستطيع ان تنفق على شعوبها اذا كانت
الزياده السكانيه وانت الان تحدثتم عن مصر
لا انا بدي اتحدث لك عن كل الدول العربيه
يا دكتور روح للاردن هالمره برايك سالنا
الناس هل يجب ان يرتبط عدد الابناء بمستوى
الدخل ونرجع لكم سيد اسماء دكتور
البلد محدود الدخل يعني يجيب اولاد كثير
ما هو مشكله في المعيشه الدوله
التعليم ولا الصحه مضبوط ويعني همم يعني
الولد راح يتغلب في همم في البلد المعيشته
تكون ضعيفه هذه رزقه الاطفال رزقه يعني
انا مثلا مثال يعني ما بخلف ما عندي اطفال
بالمره ربنا سبحانه وتعالى اراد لان انا
اكون من غير اطفال بس انما لو اراد ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى يرزقني مش راح اقصر
واحد اثنين ثلاثه هو عطاء رباني وربنا
سبحانه وتعالى بيرزقنا وبيرزقهم يعني
اكيد بس برده الواحد لازم
يا كريم
التربيه والتعليم وبالصحه
طيب سيده اسماء بالحديث عن حق الاولاد في
التربيه والصحه والتعليم ما رايك بالمقوله
الشعبيه اللي تقول كل طفل يجيب رزقه
وبركته معه الا اما ده اثبتت انها واقعيه
او عكس ذلك
والله ربنا يرزق الجميع يا حبيبتي بس هذا
الكلام يعني اوكي ربنا هو الرازق واحنا
مؤمنين وبنعرف الكلام هذا صح لكن الاطفال
بحاجه لتعليم بحاجه للصحه بحاجه لاشباها
عاطفيه يعني اذا كان الواحد عنده عشر
ابناء كيف بدي يلاحق يقعد معاهم ينصحهم
يوجههم ويربيهم ثاني شيء يعني دائما انا
بحكي عن لما نحكي عن تنظيم الاسره ما
بنحكي عن تحديد الاسره لما رغيف الخبز بدك
تيجي على اثنين اكيد بكون مشبع انا ما بدك
تسمع على اربعه بيكون اخف شويه لما بدك
تقسمه على سته شو بدهم ياكلوا
فاحنا بنحكي ماشي الارزاق بيد الله لكن
الله سبحانه وتعالى اعطانا العقل المميز
يعني في الزمنات يعني كثير كانوا مثلا
اهالينا ظروف اهالينا بتختلف عن ظروفنا
احنا وظروفنا احنا بتختلف عن ظروف ابنائنا
وظروف ابناءنا بتختلف عن ظروف احفادنا
لذلك نحن اللازم نجار الزمان يحسن التعليم
مكلف بالصحه مكلفه الابناء بدهم اشباح طفل
وهذا شيء جدا مهم نرجع يعني الاستاذه مريم
لما حكت ان يعني الفقير لازم يحدد او ينظم
بينما الوضع المادي مش مشكله انا باقول لا
الجهتين لازم يكون في تنظيم
اسره لازم يكون يعني حتى الامور كثير
الاطفال بحاجتها مش بس التعليم ولكن الصحه
ولا ولا هذول الاشياء الاساسيه لكن في
امور احنا بنعرف الزمن هذا كيف طاير يعني
لما الام موظفه والاب موظفه المفروض يكون
في وقت للابناء لذلك يعني انا ما هو بشده
مع التنظيم الاسره الحال يعني احنا بن
المصطلح تعديل نفس لكن طبيعه الحال هلا
سنه الزواج للاناث يعني من 20 فما فوق لما
يكون في فاصل بين كل طفل والثاني اربع
سنين خمس سنين وصلت الام ل 35 وهذا السن
على ما اعتقد يعني المناسب لسن الانجاب
فخلص بطبيعه الحال نظبط جابت الثلاثه
اربعه بالكثير شكرا جزيلا من عمان
سليمان الطويسي ونشكر الاختصاص الاجتماعي
الدكتور حسين الخزعلي شكرا جزيلا لكم